personal let me start over your talent
is gonna fill the garden the time in
which you fill the garden is gonna have
a whole lot more to do with the [ __ ] you
do on those platforms and YouTube and
podcasts it's just the truth based on my
thesis that hip-hop rules the world it's
probably a fifty billion dollar company
if you was a thesis hip-hop rules the
world
[Music]
when didn't you know you were good for
real and I got in a booth like a real
studio how did that happen
I wasn't fluid on house arrest I wasn't
supposed to go outside right
yep huh and I told him I was nonsense
though and I went to the studio but I
ain't came I had to do that you just
just had to get it yeah so nobody that
that's amazing and what literally as
soon as you were done you're like [ __ ] I
got this
yeah every day I was panicking I was in
the studio a lot like I used to tell my
mom no lie so my mom finished shopping
and then after I started time and now
I'm all says to do are you giving any of
your music or or jamming at all with any
of the twitch stars so twitch are you
guys from twitch twitch is a platform
where people so know people people play
video games and people watch them
playing so one of the most interesting
places I think you can win on so I said
boys turned this too many times so as
d-roc but it's just I can't get over it
I'm a little older Good Charlotte the
band they got put on because they were
the music when you were
your team on Madden back in the day 15
years ago nobody knew who the [ __ ] they
were but when you were picking your team
on Madden and you heard the hook over
and over for five minutes two minutes
right right it's continued since then I
don't I don't get to play as much
anymore so I don't know who's been put
on who's not but I can tell you flat-out
they got famous just cuz I believe one
of the great moves right now for more
exposure more than you're naturally
gonna get with Instagram you're gonna
win
that shit's unlock you're gonna win
you've won and you're gonna win more but
when I hear you say I want to spread out
and be more impactful brand that's not
just gonna naturally come to me I want
to go like this not just deep but I want
to go a little wider if you want to go
wider you can go through the process of
Viacom Nickelodeon agents EA a WMA when
you have flex you can go through the
Machine you've done it you're on a
record you know but that has so much
speed to it or you can go directly to
what you're looking to do I think one
thing that you guys should give a lot of
thought to is figure out what the top
500 twitch players are top thousand
twitch players are figure out how many
of them I'm gonna tell you right now
seven of them [ __ ] with you and love you
reach out to the same as this right now
them playing games to some of your songs
and things that nature has a profound
effect on more reach in new areas
achieving the same thing that you're
thinking about for a broad brand
standpoint in a way where there's no
friction it's just somebody that's just
like you except they know how to play
fifa you know or how much do you guys
think about how much you guys think
about like what's naturally gonna come
to you cuz it's just part of that
culture versus how you think about
somebody who loves country music or
somebody lives in Brazil
if you think like I for example like I'm
a rapper right no America I'm gonna use
any other rapper 2 Chainz I was a 2
Chainz last night he's from America
young young doll from America we all no
matter how much fans we get in America
we all kind of have the same fan base
that's right intelligence that's exactly
right I mean so if we if we step outside
the box there's no right it's it's no
like it's no it's a different race now
uh-huh you got more land to grab how do
you guys think about volume music one
thing I'm spending a ton of time on is
I'm fascinated by people's strategy on
how much or how little music they put
out how do you guys think about that
like I I'm so fascinated because I think
it's so hard to be overexposed cuz the
world so fragmented now so I'm trying to
push kids to like I'm like more more I'm
like you got a [ __ ] hit in your head
right now like I'm more more and more
and a lot of people get precious they're
like especially when they give albums
like you know I've been doing mixtapes
I've been putting out something to
Spotify every day it's all about how
they get reactions and Tommy time and
reactions if I dropped my album and I
get a great reaction if I said 150 in a
week I might drop another album but if
it's doing bad I want that out to keep
on growing understand those actually
this is actually where some where we
might be able to help when it goes bad
or album or song goes bad which for you
it's never bad but not where you want it
to be yeah what the [ __ ] do you guys do
to make sure like just sitting do you
sit and wait because you have such great
brand that'll just get there or are you
proactively trying to produce content
around that music to get it there yes we
try to like move away from there
yeah because people think that's corny
yeah be more natural with it we look
below things like you know what I think
is a big opportunity that nobody's
exploiting in that vein so I agree with
you because it looks like desperation
right one of the things that I think you
should I should think about that I
haven't said finally getting some new
stuff but been thinking about this one I
think that's where the last two things I
asked you about could combined I think
instead of doing something cheesy or
trying to jab it up this is where you
can give access to your fans like I
still think so you got a song that you
real believe in right and it just not go
in that way that's where I think you can
use social perfect just out of nowhere
be like tonight I'm gonna give you I'm
gonna give you two more hints I'm just
gonna perform in the middle of some like
here like in this alleyway you play with
your fans a little bit people get their
juices going and then you get you know
3,500 6,000 people there but you record
it and you give love to your fans a
little bit spend an extra 10 15 minutes
giving a couple selfies it's a way for
you to give real love to your fans and
it could lead to the piece of content
that puts that song on because
everybody's gonna share the [ __ ] out of
it so something to think about I mean I
spent a lot of time not wanting to do
the cheesy move trying to do the hard
move yeah I did a meet-up in like
Washington State Park I was like I have
a shot of God and like let's you give it
you have your new book coming out me and
you like let's just let's just tweet at
each other at 3 o'clock let's meet
somewhere people got going a little bit
you know hundreds and hundreds of people
showed up pictures content did it and no
what's crazy 600 people were like oh my
god like yes I knew I loved him like
he's real he's good he gave love but the
amplification of those 600 in their
content your your content d-roc filmed
it like it might be a way for you to
really put a little bit of a match on
something and you won twice instead of
going cheesy you gave love to the people
that put you here in the first place and
you gave that song another chance so
something to think about I don't I'm an
extrovert I want to be around people so
it's it's a tough piece of advice
because I don't know how everybody rolls
you know want maybe 600 people like
clamming on you I
no but that's something to think about
we're just calling people facetiming
them I'm obsessed with depth versus with
I'm obsessed with that I think people
even you said earlier right like listen
I got 2.2 million followers like I'm
think about 2.3 you can't help it that's
human behavior but I think it's super
important that you know there's two
point to get you know what are you doing
on social besides Instagram you really
should because I was look cuz I knew we
were getting together like obviously
that's my whole world I'm like [ __ ] man
this guy puts in a you know because
that's honestly that's how I think you
feel the garden personal let me start
over your talent is gonna fill the
garden the time in which you fill the
garden is gonna have a whole lot more to
do with the [ __ ] you do on those
platforms and YouTube and podcasts it's
just the truth it's you know you see
back in the day MTV put you on BT put
you on vine cool that's how it happened
the source puts you on the cover good
that's just not the world we live in a
fragmentation and the bet that's the
best because you're in control notice
yet back at it see you never do this to
[ __ ] me see god I never made up but see
God I make a bill